welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer regarding to the Galaxy vol 3
from the Super Bowl teasing a movie
whose plot is still largely a mystery
but it seems like everyone's gonna die
except this little monster whose name is
apparently blur blurb is the sound that
I make when I see a movie I really want
to like but then when the credits roll
it ends up being a well well a blur but
I'm sure that won't be the case with
this movie better not let's break down
this trailer frame by frame for the
interesting and heartbreaking details
that you might have missed and thanks to
Rocket money for sponsoring today's vid
more about them in a minute the trailer
opens with this atypically grounded
moment Peter Quill drowning at sorrows
with booze alone at the same bar where
he drank by himself on nowhere in the
Guardians holiday special and that's
special he was at least cheered up by
mantis giving him a good Christmas and
revealing they were half siblings both
of them children of the celestial ego
now he seems bummed again contextually
from this trailer at least missing
Gamora the music is Rainbow's 1979 since
you've been gone and we know James
Gunn's song selection is always
thematically and emotionally resonant to
the characters in this case the speaker
of the song is haunted by nightly
nightmares of a breakup which on the
surface seems to refer to Peter and
Gamora but this opening shot is not from
Peter's perspective it's from Rocket's
point of view we do not see his face and
from that we can infer that rocket is
from the heartbroken one he has been
broken ever since Lila has been gone but
the second verse of the song refers to a
cruel breakup letter your poison letter
your telegram just goes to show you
don't give a damn just a reminder that
all of James Gunn's Guardians movies are
letters from Quill's parents the two
mixtapes from his mother Meredith and
now the Zune left to him by yondu I
wonder if in this third movie Peter's
depression causes him to see these
messages as toxic poison letters that
just make things worse for him but look
closely at Rocket's hand in the shot I
think he's actually bringing Peter that
soon and Peter may not be in a place in
this scene where he wants to hear it we
do know from the previous trailer that
he does listen to the zoo at a critical
moment while he's standing on the bridge
of the Bowie also by the way rainbows
since you've been gone was also featured
in the soundtrack of the Guardians of
the Galaxy video game the tipped over
bottle that Peter drinks from looks like
it has scroll writing on the label
though it's just hard to make out what
exactly it says I just love how the
trailer editing syncs Peter fire and his
blasters with the chords of the song I'm
Star-Lord
the holiday special also confirmed that
these blasters were Christmas gifts to
Young Peter from yondu Peter reminds us
that Gamora died in Avengers Infinity
War but then return an Avengers endgame
as a 2014 era variant of herself when
thanos's forces traveled to the present
this Gamora has no memory of her past
with Peter anything that happened in
those two Guardians movies so when we
love someone do we love the memories
that we share together the things that
we did to win each other over or is
there some Mystic Force in our souls
that binds us together independent from
memory Gamora shoves Peter into some
navigation or control screens they're
both wearing these red orange jumpsuits
which is what they are wearing in that
mysterious bright location so Gamora
might not be generally being a dick when
she pushes Peter but it could just be
some rightful frustration over his
mission mistakes these jumpsuits have a
vertical collar strip with four symbols
the same symbol on every color they look
like stick figures with nodes on the end
I guess they kind of look like those
homeomorphically irreducible trees you
know the math problem from Goodwill
Hunting but I assume this is some kind
of chain code for visitors at this
facility this pink skinned woman with
them in the elevator is actress Daniela
melchior whom James Gunn said would be
in this movie after she played red
catcher 2 in his DC film The Suicide
Squad she is a similar nodal
configuration on her name tag now I have
to imagine this is an important
character Daniella melchior is playing
her and I think there's some connection
between her pink skin and all of these
name tags to a theory that I'm going to
talk about at the end of this breakdown
notice how nebula has a new arm upgrade
a chain mail-like substance that she did
not have in the Guardians holiday
special so this is a recent addition
later on we see why this weave allows
her to shape-shift her arm into any
metallic shape I don't like the T-1000
in Terminator 2 but also it looks like
the structure of the Sentinels in X-Men
Days of Future Past and Peter is
carrying this diamond pattern sphere
that we see him carry in other shots in
this location presumably an object of
some imports okay we find ourselves in
the cockpit of the Bowie the guardian's
new ship after the Milano and the first
two Guardians films and the Benetar and
infinity war and end game this one
obviously named after David Bowie they
are approaching this Earth-like planet
mostly ocean covered there are some
polarized caps but as we saw in the
first trailer this seems to be Earth but
it's actually the high evolutionaries
artificial Planet counter Earth kind of
heard this name of the planet in the
comics that he locates like a half
millisecond out of dimensional sync with
Earth whatever that means but here in
this movie he's populated this planet
with these animalistic hybrids like
rocket or maybe when he initially hoped
rocket would become we know rocket and
Lila are from half world but it seems
like they're part of the high
evolutionaries experimental new men he's
known for creating these hybrids like
Boba the cow creature who nursed both
Pietro and Wanda maximoth now here we
see two different shots two different
eras of the high evolutionary a wide
shot on his ship with a scientists where
he's younger he has hair and then this
close-up of his present-day form where
he's bald and has his facial skin tucked
back to give himself I guess a creepy
facelift I mean you gotta keep yourself
young somehow right so we are going to
see him in his early years when he
created rocket and then in his later
years where I guess they're going to
reunite yes a reminder that the high
evolutionary is considered Marvel's top
geneticist a colleague of the X-Men
villain Nathaniel Essex Mr Sinister so
the Bowie arrives through this hexagonal
untn grid to approach the red cubic
structure what I assume is a high
evolutionary ship we know this is going
to be in atmosphere in other trailer
clips I love how each hexagon in the
grid is made up of hundreds of smaller
hexagons as if to suggest each one is a
different exact point in known space
that you can be directed to Windham
declares that his sacred mission is to
create the perfect Society sacred
Mission sacred timeline I don't know it
could just be coincidental religious
fanaticism for their respective causes
it is possible that these two were
colleagues or at least aware of each
other oh God we see Rocket's tiny body
and restraints within that chamber of
the room where younger Wyndham stroll
through earlier and here you can see
Windham on the left looking down at
Rocket I hate to notice things like this
but rocket is totally trembling in those
restraints remember rocket is not a
raccoon he's just a space rodent that
wouldn't have engineered matching the
likeness of Earth's raccoon we see a
close-up of 8-9 p13 being tattooed this
number showed up on Rocket's booking
screen when he got arrested on xandar in
the 2014 film and now it looks like it's
being tattooed somewhere on Rocket skin
or his skull ugh Mt actually had an
interesting theory that eight nine could
stand for 1989 one year after Peter Paul
got abducted by the ravagers and I know
1989 doesn't necessarily apply because
Tara and years aren't really used for
the interplanetary calendar in the MCU
but 1989 could be the year Windham set
his 80s Suburban counter Earth in
because they're all wearing 80s clothes
and drive 80s cars and Rocket confirms
that Windham didn't care about a perfect
Society he just hated the way things are
which is a fascinating commentary on
perfectionism it's not about
realistically attaining an ideal it's
about an inner failure to accept one's
reality nothing can ever be good enough
let's move on as in the first trailer
five of the Guardians mantis tracks
Peter nebula and gamora's spacewalk in
these multi-colored suits that I know I
know everyone thinks are based on Among
Us and the color scheme does match that
but James can confirmed that these are
actually nods to the space suits in 2001
A Space Odyssey which also is the idea
behind our bossmanat logo and our new
collection of Deep dive merch which you
can get at nerd riot.shop this Friday
February 17th will be the launch of our
new channel the Deep dive in which
you're gonna be able to see five awesome
videos on launch day including my live
breakdown of Batman the watch
quantumania so subscribe over at Deep
dive NR and really the best way you can
support our entire Network here at new
rockstars is to get your hands on our
nerdy merch like this quantumania
inspired shirt nerd riot.shop half the
fun of the Super Bowl is the ads but to
get that fun looking stuff you gotta
have some money rocket money can help
with that it makes saving money easy
rocket money used to be true bill but
true bill mutated from a bill management
app into a full-on money management
Powerhouse rocket money rocket money
does everything true bill did and more
helping 3.4 million members take control
of their finances with easy to use
features that put you back in charge of
your finances one of rocketmundy's best
features is that it helps you find and
cancel all your unwanted subscriptions I
was wasting hundreds of dollars every
month on stuff I didn't even use and now
I can use rocketmoney's Smart savings
account to put that money aside instead
I just choose the amount I want to save
and how frequently rocket money
automatically deposits my money into a
savings fund that I can withdraw from
anytime for the money I'm spending
instead of saving I use the budgeting
tool it monitors my spending by category
sends notifications when I've exceeded
my spending limits and visualizes my
spin to earn ratio by month quarter or
year rocket money can even negotiate
bills from internet service bills to
cable and phone bills I didn't even know
those could be negotiated just upload a
photo of your bill and Rocket money does
the rest once you've signed up you can
unlock even more features in premium
it's so easy to use and there's no
reason not to take control of your
finances to try rocket money out for
free and support our Channel head to
rocketmoney.com new rockstars or click
the link in the video description now
this massive form that there's space
walking down onto looks fleshy it has
hairs and as I speculated before this
might be Celestial tissue part of the
corpse of nowhere from the rest of his
body or maybe another Celestial being
picked apart or artificially created
that also ties into my theory that I'll
get to it in this video Peter and Groot
face a smug looking Herbert Wyndham and
a brief shot of Cracklin as he holds the
yaka arrow in perfect alignment with his
head thin kind of meditation as he tries
to become one with the arrow as chaos
unfolds around him on nowhere there's
one quick really weird shot of a figure
crawling up a catwalk or a ladder using
mechanized exoskeleton arms as these
bright Chambers open around them we
might see the broken pieces of this
apparatus a little later in the trailer
Windham orders incinerate them probably
what he as a younger scientist plan to
do with rocket and Lila and other lab
experiments that he is no longer in use
for Adam Warlock shows up this is what
Aisha was brewing up in that golden
cocoon in the Guardians Volume 2 post
credit scene he's a much bigger
character in the comics who has one of
the Infinity Stones plugged into his
head here just looks like a gem or a
bolt of some kind here we see Adam
flying through this neighborhood that
explodes around him I'm pretty sure this
is the 80s suburb that the Guardians
land on in the first trailer he seems to
be pursuing Gamora carrying an
incapacitated rocket back to the Bowie
telling me that the Guardians came to
this planet to try to rescue rocket what
was he doing there to begin with
presumably to find out more about his
past okay swole group drops from a
higher platform in nowhere to stomp on
and Tackle Adam Warlock though notice
how he only gets Adam in like a loose
headlock I think Adam isn't going to be
too affected by this pounce rocket Lila
have a laugh in their cages and this
flashback Lila is the otter type
creature in the love of Rocket's life
her name showed up on his bookings
screen in the 2014 film as well you can
see she has a mechanical ARM Holding
Onto her belly as they laugh but notice
how Rocket's head is now wider now more
shaped as we know him as an adult
compared to the more narrow shape before
his surgery and by the way in that shot
where you can see windham's hand
reaching in to grab young rocket anybody
who has ever trained a rescue dog knows
that you should never reach it and pet a
dog with your hand like that it can
trigger the dog you always reach an
underhand like that obviously Herbert
window doesn't give a about that
but either way the changing shape of
Rocket's head tells us that it was
intentional to change his skull shape to
make it more humanoid to make it more
like a lollipop on a bipedal body which
is totally unnatural for a raccoon we
get various shots of quill and swole
Groot back to back shooting up windham's
group Cosmo the space dog looks up at us
Cosmo came back in the holiday special
and will once again be voiced by Maria
bakalova quick shot of Peter lying
across gamora's body as she holds this
furry little guy we don't know much
about him other than James gun tweeting
his name is blurp I assume this is
another one of windham's Creations now
during the shootout rocket climbs up
groot's shoulder recreating the famous
pose from the shootout in the Kiln
prison in the first Guardians film and
Peter and Groot attack windham's men if
you look closely dinner has just
attached an explosive or something to
the butt of the guy on the right I love
it moving on So Adam Warlock locks
glowing Sabers with Drax as the heat
seems to affect the side of drax's face
actually early in the trailer when he
seemed to be charred on that side of his
head it might have come from this duel
the Guardians all emotionally salute
they look like they're at the end of a
battle they're pretty roughed up maybe
they're saluting one of their own Fallen
Guardians Drax and the others Riot and
his white facility throwing these men in
these fleshy beef suits against this
device that is yellow fluid flowing
through it remember when the collector
was still mining nowhere for spinal
fluid that fluid was the same color
yellow was also the color of the blood
of the avalisk that Drax cut through in
volume 2. I wonder if this whole
facility could be an operation to either
build an artificial Celestial that
Windham can control or to use Celestial
tissue to give himself the powers to
originate life with the power of a god
notice as Drax fights these guys you can
totally see Windham on all of the
screens there as quill has his armor on
nebula honestly if you can see a patch
with some alien writing and then a logo
that is in the shape of an X with an
interest in one of these shapes you know
what that is but the text isn't clear
enough to translate but I have a good
idea of what it might say more on that
in a bit the high evolutionary with his
legs crossed floats down this exploding
hallway his purple suit is illuminated
now the high evolutionary in the comics
Fashions themselves a mentally evolved
life form but I think here he might just
be using a kind of neurokinetic suit
that allows him to levitate like this
this Tech isn't that dissimilar to what
Kan uses in quantumania and then we get
various shots of all the main characters
crying watching someone leave looking
generally heartbroken and again this
shot from the first trailer of Peter
screaming in agony with a metal tube
next to his face someone is dying right
in front of him and the bow would Blast
away from whatever this fleshy structure
is and it's Central orifice so they
might have been either on a heist or on
a mission to destroy this thing either
way probably to foil windham's overall
plan onto the final clip whoever it was
that you you were in love with it sounds
more like her hers do not bring me into
them
knock it off what damn our man quill is
thirsty the way he looks at nebula is a
lot like the way Thor looked at him in
Thor 11 Thunder to show what it looks
like when you love someone remember what
I told you
you ever feel lost
just look into the eyes of the people
that you love
they'll tell you exactly who you are
all right bye nebula reminds us that of
course her black eyes were implants
given to her by Thanos as a torture
method and so giving herself that
shape-shifting weave arm might be a
stepper nebula back toward owning her
own body I love it but the context we
are overlooking here is that they are
totally having this debate while Gamora
is holding someone at gunpoint someone
off screen maybe Daniela melchior's
character who they were just with or
maybe someone else that we know why does
malvior's character have pink skin could
she be related to maybe be the same type
of assistant as Karina the 8 to 10
Elyria Tavon The Collector good all of
these patches on their uniform and
jumpsuits translate to Tavon mining
Corporation or whatever new LLC he's
filed his business license under because
it's still a pretty big mystery why the
collector would be willing to part ways
with nowhere but we know he survived
because we saw his ship flying by the
frame in the opening shot of the Loki
season 1 finale so did Tanner later
Tavon find a new chunk of celestial Mass
to mine and that's why he sold the empty
husk of nowhere to the Guardians much
like Daniel Plainview selling off oil
Baron Landing Eli after he had already
drank that milkshake
another reminder to subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive launching this
Friday with five five premium videos
that you are gonna love you can follow
me on Instagram and Twitter ate boss
follow new rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]